this is JM Daniel nitzki we are watching
Magnus Carlson taking on Hikaru Nakamura
in an Armageddon game at the 2023
Champions chest to finals Magnus oh 15
minutes I guess that means you win it
and both sides they're putting in their
beds Magnus Carlson bid 15 minutes which
means he insists on having the white
pieces but hikaro will have 9 minutes
and 40 seconds to start the game as well
as draw odds if the game ends in a draw
then hikaro Nakamura takes the match and
they are off game is underway it is
Carlson versus Nakamura with Hikaru
handling the black pieces he has draw on
so if this game ends in a draw then
hikaro will have defeated Carlson in
their mini match and what a surprise
early on in the game Hikaru as saying a
pat that's not the surprise but he takes
on e4 traditionally this is not
considered to be a good move because of
Queen E2 but Magnus immediately deviates
from the known Theory Hikaru might have
prepared a tricky line instead Magnus
chasing away hikaru's Knight and then
pushing the pawn up to D4 Hikaru
reciprocates with D5 and now the
position is very symmetrical indeed the
only difference is that Magnus has
ensconced that Knight on E5 he might
have a very small Edge because of that
as the players continue to develop their
pieces making moves quickly both sides
Castle to the king side and now
presumably Magnus is going to continue
developing Bishop to G5 uh looks like a
pretty good spot for whites dark squ
Bishop the knight from B1 it can come
out to C3 but often that's an
inadvisable method of development
because it actually blocks the C2 Pawn
which can advance up to C4 and challenge
Black's control of the center Hikaru
very surprised it seems at Carlson's
choice to develop the bishop to F4 where
it ensures that the Knight on E5 is
going to be extra well protected and
maybe Hikaru can do what Magnus wants to
do eventually and challenge White's
control of the center with C5 that
Knight on E5 is going to be a major
problem for black how is Hikaru going to
work around that Knight a little bit of
hesitation there Hikaru playing a pretty
standard move Rook E8 adding some
pressure to that Knight on E5 the battle
is revolving around the center now it's
magnus's turn Magnus Carlson taking his
time he's almost done with his
development and that decision to develop
his dark sored Bishop to F4 rather than
G5 let's see if that will end up helping
him or hurting him all son fidgeting
with the only Pawn that he has captured
thus far and coping hikaro Nakamura he
brings his own Rook his own Tower to the
open file and there it is there is that
C5 move hikaro adopting a very
principled way of fighting White's
control over the center challenging the
D4 pawn and trying to undermine the
support of the E5 Knight and there it is
he's finally made a move and it is in
fact Knight C3 the spiciest of the
candidate moves that we had outlined he
simply leaves the D4 Pawn he says hikaro
I don't care you can take it my knight
is heading to B5 and after C takes D4
the Knight will almost certainly jump to
B5 hitting Black's Bishop on D6 is he
going to take the plunge and grab
Carlson's Pawn on D4 allow the knight
from C3 to jump to B5 or is he going to
go for a Tamer option maybe Knight C6
maybe even a move like A6 in order to
contain the mobility of the Knight on C3
but of course iaru hasn't completed his
development either and so he buys
himself a Tempo he chooses the
relatively quiet move C4 keeping the
pawn structure intact in the center and
Magnus actually drops his Bishop to E2 I
was expecting Bishop F1 and there we go
both sides have now completed their
development Hikaru develops his Knight
to C6 and now the light scared Bishop
slides up to E6 adding an important
Defender to the D5 Pawn so the most
tempting move for white here is Bishop
to G5 trying to eliminate the F6 Knight
and ultimately get to the D5 Pawn I
don't think it would be a good idea for
white to trade on C6 while that would
ruin Black's Pawn structure on the
surface the B7 Pawn would slide up to C6
and the D5 Pawn would be very safely
protected White's light squ Bishop would
not look good at all and Bishop back to
E7 what an interesting move by Nakamura
the bishop Retreats adding another
Defender to the D5 Pawn now Black's
Queen is participating in the defensive
task I think Karo is trying to take the
sting out of a potential Bishop Sally to
G5 Magnus might have to find another
area of the board to play on the D5 Pawn
is now protected by three separate
pieces how is Magnus going to prosecute
his initiative and B3 is his choice he's
going at it from the other side rather
than attacking the base of the pawn
chain he's going after the tip of the
pawn chain engineering a trade of Pawns
on the queen side how is he going to
recapture well um our M taught us that
the best ways to recapture toward the
center a takes B3 would open up that
Rook on A1 it would allow white to exert
a little bit of pressure on the A7 Pawn
obviously hikaru's position is ultra
solid at the time but Magnus has that
space Advantage he still has his Knight
nicely sitting on E5 and if Hikaru is
the one to take on E5 Magnus might be
able to recapture with a pawn and then
the D5 Pawn is likely to fall and so
hikaro is working around that Knight
instead Bishop to B4 is an excellent
move there it is Knight to D3 not a
happy camper as Carlson is forced to Vol
voluntarily drop his Knight back from E5
and Chase that Bishop away from B4 now
notice Knight takes D4 is not possible
here because the bishop on B4 will hang
uh and the bishop on F3 is protected by
the G2 pawn and he takes on C3 why did
he do that look at how Hikaru is
handling this middle game he is just
trying to get as many pieces off the
board as possible and his follow-up move
Bishop to G4 forces the light squirt
Bishops off the board Magnus will now
have no choice but to acquest to the
trade of Bishops first he grabs The Rook
lots more pieces are coming off the
board a pair of Rooks now the Bishops
and now white no longer has the bishop
pair and Hikaru has that E4 square that
he could try to sink his teeth into when
the Knight moves back from G4 to F6 but
the downside of hikaru's campaign to
trade all of the pieces is that he's
given away control of the E file the E
file is the most important Avenue in
this board and now white has firm
control of that file Agnes kind of
raising his eyebrows almost indicating
that he just doesn't see anything that
appeals to him but he has to find a way
to keep the games going finally Carlson
deciding on H3 chasing the Knight away
and Knight to B4 what an interesting
decision by Carlson and Hikaru was
either very happy to see that or very
surprised to see that Magnus offering a
trade of knights and maybe hikaro is
surprised that Carlson is voluntarily
trading off the horses but clearly
there's a lot more to this move than
might meet the eye so Knight takes B4
would lead to a trade of knights and
White's Queen would jump into B4 black
could then take the pawn on C2 but white
would reciprocate by capturing on B7
hikaro could also stick his Knight on e4
and now it's hikaru's turn to calculate
the variations so the options are Knight
E4 which is likely and it's been played
Knight to E4 is on the board and indeed
Knight takes C6 and look at hikaro he
takes not White's Queen but instead
White's Knight and another pair of minor
pieces has now come off the board we
have a bishop versus knight imbalance
Hikaru has entrenched a knight on e4 but
that's not an outpost white could chase
that Knight away in the future with a
move F3 he can bring it up to A5 and he
does Queen to A5 attacking the pawn on
A7 keeping Black's Rook at Bay and
there's a sense in which Hikaru is under
a little bit of pressure here he's got a
lot of weaknesses on the queen side his
Pawn on D5 is no longer isolated but
instead its neighbor on C6 that's a
long-term weakness the pawn on A7 is
isolated and it's being pressured by
White's Queen that's a long-term
weakness White's Bishop on F4 has access
to a lot of good dark squares on black
side of the board the E5 Square could be
used as a base of operations hearo has
to tread carefully here as he pushes H5
grabbing space on the king side and
making a space for his King on H7 now he
will not have to deal with the weakness
of his back Rank and there we go Magnus
chases the Knight back to F6 now the
Knight on F6 is completely restricted by
The Pawn on F3 and its neighbor on H3
Magnus will have to make a decision
momentarily time continues to take down
so what are the options here for Carlson
he could try to get the Queens off the
board but that doesn't seem like a very
good idea because his King seems to be a
little bit safer than blacks even though
he's got more pawns pushed in front of
his King the bishop is generally better
in these open board situations there's
no question that white is in the
driver's seat but there aren't a lot of
pieces left and Carlson has to continue
making more problems for black Rook to
E5 what a decision rather than putting
the bishop on E5 he puts his tower on E5
and he challenges the H5 pawn and hekar
doesn't seem too happy to to see that
and queen to D7 moving the queen up and
protecting A7 and preparing to swap
Rooks with Rook E8 and with every piece
that comes off the board Black's
defensive task becomes easier and easier
and the significance of Black's weakened
King continues to diminish hearu adopts
a more relaxed posture Queen to D7 was a
nice calm reaction and Carlson brings
his own Queen brings that lady back from
A5 to E1 as it zigzags from one side of
the board to the other and very likely
Carlson is assembling his forces
whatever remains of them to try a last
second attack on Black's King that Queen
might be heading for G3 it might be
trying to x-ray the G7 Pawn but hearu
continues to push his campaign and
continues to bring pieces off the board
Rook to E8 and now Carlson has no choice
but to acques to the trade of Rooks but
he plays Queen to H4 and if Hikaru would
have grabbed E5 Carlson would have
recaptured with the pawn and sent
Black's Knight away and picked up the H5
Pawn so instead Hikaru keeps the tension
with Rook e six but Queen to G5 is
another really nice move and look at the
way that Carlson is tightening the
screws and attacking all of Black's
weaknesses now the G7 Pawn is under Fire
the trade of Rooks is still not in
Black's favor because once again Carlson
can recapture with a pawn and send the
Knight away and win the H5 pawn and now
Hikaru dropping on the clock and showing
signs of panic how is Hikaru going to
keep his weaknesses defended in G6 what
a committal move by Hikaru as he creates
massive kingside weaknesses and now all
of the dark around his King are Ultra
weak Carlson says thank you very much
and he trades Rooks he's likely going to
put his Bishop on E5 and that might
spell a lot of trouble for black because
once his Bishop lands on E5 he's
actually going to have M threats against
Black's King the queen can infiltrate to
H6 it can infiltrate to d8 well Hikaru
has to take on E6 with the queen he's
not thinking about the current move he's
likely thinking what have I just done
why have I allowed Magnus to infiltrate
all of the dark squares around my king
it says at all his facial reactions say
it all and hikaro is not happy but he's
got to keep fighting he's got to
recapture on E6 with a queen if he takes
on E6 with the pawn he simply drops the
Knight on F6 and I think Karu is
seriously regretting his previous move
he is showing signs of disappointment
after Bishop to E5 his Knight will
simply not have a good Square there it
is Bishop E5 the instant reaction by
Carlson now the Knight is going to have
to move away from F7 technically hikaro
can defend the Knight with King G7 but
is going to be pinning his Knight
forever that doesn't seem to be a viable
option instead he has to allow the
infiltration of White's Queen to d8 or
to H6 so maybe Knight D7 is the Lesser
evil no Knight D7 loses that Knight has
to go all the way back to E8 but now the
queen infiltrates to H6 and Carlson has
fully infiltrated Queen h8 and queen H7
the king is getting harassed and there
goes the A7 Pawn finally it's time for
Magnus Carlson to collect his Harvest he
is now a pawn to the good and most
importantly most worryingly for black
it's not just the pawn on A7 which
disappears the attack continues Black's
position is riddled with holes but
Hikaru continues to fight he brings that
Knight back to F6 eventually he will try
to move back to D7 and get that irom
Bishop off of E5 hearu moves his King to
E8 all hands on deck for hikaro Nakamura
but now the queen can continue to zigzag
from the queen side to the king side the
C6 Pawn is weak the G6 Pawn is weak and
can hearo keep everything contained as
Magnus Carlson very patiently this is a
typical Magnus move the king moves up to
H2 and gets away from the line of fire
of Black's Queen now if White's bishop
ever moves away from E5 there will not
be a check on E1 Hikaru Nakamura will
have zero counterplay against White's
Queen and Hikaru continues to shake his
head this game uh is spiraling out of
control he is now upon down his position
is full of weaknesses and his clock time
is dwindling down to zero Hikaru has no
moves here he can move the Knight back
instead he angrily pushes his Pawn to H4
trying to create maybe the preconditions
for some sort of counterplay against
White's King maybe getting that H5
Square for his Knight and Carlson has to
continue the pressure right he still
hasn't won the game maybe he can push C4
and try to create a passer on the queen
side maybe he can push B4 and toss the
ball back into Black's Court I don't see
a forced win here uh he can throw in
that check on B8 he can play Queen B8
check but instead Bishop to D6
continuing to in trate down the dark
squares hikaro offers a trade of Queens
the danger if if Carlson accepts that
trade is that hikaro will be able to
build some sort of a fortress his
queenside pawns are on light squares and
Carlson does indeed trade the Queens but
look at his Bishop as it definely
adroitly Maneuvers back to F4
threatening to infiltrate to G5 now it
moves back to D2 but how is Carlson
going to break yar's last line of
defense Bishop to E1 and both sides
blitzing their moves an F4 amazing move
undermining Black's Pawn chain now
Carlson has a pass Pawn on H3 that's an
outside passer and he brings his King
back to G1 as it zigzags up to F2 if
Carlson can get to hikaru's Pawn on F4
then the game will be over that would be
two extra pawns he cared with just a
couple of seconds on his clock as he
instantly moves his Knight back up to E6
but he's not going to be able to keep
everything protected he's given up the
pawn in F4 and he has extended his hand
in resignation what an incredible
surgical positional effort by Magnus
Carlson as he manages to take down
hikaro Nakamura in an OnDemand victory
in the Armageddon game of their 2023 CCT
finals match what a game it was I hope
you enjoyed watching thank you so much
and I hope to see you in a video
soon